it's the left you have a true evil when
you work diligently to keep people
hopeless and uneducated that's what I
call evil the order state of California
with 75% of blackboard state of
California 2017 cannot pass standard
reading and writing tests when young
people cannot read and write we're now
gonna talk about space course we're not
gonna have conversations like this
you're gonna turn on the network's and
be driven by emotion because they have
no hope no way of thinking no man
reasoning what kind of tractor are you
getting cuz you know it's funny the way
Twitter operates you know I see certain
personalities that are will bubble up
for a while and then I'll click a
profile I'll go oh this guy's running
for Congress in Utah this girl's running
for something in Florida something else
and you're kind of like oh well they're
sort of popular on Twitter or they make
sense here but it's a little hard to
tell from as an outsider well is this
gaining traction at home how can you
grade sort of where your campaign is
that are their weak spots that you want
to shore up but you know that kind of
thing very good
I think the blessings that I've had is
that I'd never thought about being a
politician all these years I mean
literally did not happen to look good by
this time last year so up until this
point I came out a book the person was
liberalism how to turn a good minute to
whiners whinnies and wimps and that got
me one just run the same time that
October that's a good title it really is
but it is just by the same time that
company was doing is kneeling but I had
a chance to get on and share with
America my thoughts my pride and country
and that what I saw is really being
detrimental so I had a chance to develop
some friendships throughout the time and
so now that I that I'm running I really
have an opportunity to have exposure
that's been very advantageous for me we
have a community again because we're
we're very conservative that looks at
Fox so many people knew me somewhat even
though I was in a very small niche I was
working with that risk kid so it wasn't
a learning community a whole lot but
it's been an opportunity for me first of
all to really know this this this
district a lot more than I would have
ever know I've stayed a lot better
because I'm now out talking with people
and what I'm finding is that my message
resonates we all just want to have
buddy who willing to stand and not not
wilt and not not feel ashamed but not
apologize and I tell you to be the end
of the day when God country family and
race is the most important thing before
anything else it's easy to stand it is
no big deal because if that's being
attacked then you want to run to make
sure you protect all the above and and
that's what I'm finding out cross our
country have conservatives that really
get it they don't mind taking a hit they
don't mind being called names because it
doesn't mean a thing matter of fact I
tell people call me names make sure
you're using your time right because it
doesn't impact me you might be wasting a
lot of time because it doesn't bother me
at all so and so together we get that
group together and we give this message
to those again who has been truly used
over the last few months and abused the
last few months I think we have a point
now we can start to resonate and say yes
no guys this worked together to get our
economy back to where it was a few
months ago and this time know who the
enemy is and never go back and I think
that's where we we've come out of this
through this process with yeah so I as I
said I was on your website this morning
I was looking at the issues that you
knock out one or one at a time let's
just do two or three that you're that
you're particularly passionate about you
you a leave I'll even toss them up to
you give me two or two or three that you
really care about that you think are the
core issues that can help you in a very
good burger day again everything that
I'm working with is based on those
promises life liberty and pursuit of
happiness that's the bottom line
for us to understand that we have to be
educated ignorant of free can never be
Thomas Jefferson that is so powerful and
and the left has understood that a long
time that's why they've worked very hard
to make sure was stay ignorant it's the
left you have a true evil when you work
diligently to keep people hopeless and
uneducated that's what I call evil you
go to the state of California with 75%
of the black board state of California
2017 cannot pass standard reading and
writing tests when young people cannot
read and write we're not going to talk
about space course we're not going to
have conversations like this you're
gonna turn on the network's and be
driven by emotion because they have no
hope no way of thinking no man reasoning
they'll never read the scriptures the
connection with a God in heaven will
never ever happen and you go to every
single
Breschel every single city that's owned
by the leftist by the Democrats you've
seen the exact same thing hopelessness
anger and literacy so education is
together it's gonna be a big piece now
the other part of Education is that what
you've done in higher education it's not
just the poor kids that are being
attacked is it's a rest of our kids
there's our middle class we raised our
kids in a great environment we send them
off to get a degree they come back as
little marxist hate in our country and
that they would think at all about
reasoning they've been doing this for so
long and now you see it in the streets
across the country and Tifa they're not
black kids they're they're their
middle-class yuppie in my days yuppies
what was cool I don't know if they're
still cooler or what but they're good
they're kids who have the wealth but
they hate our country what I think we
should do as personally as I told us
earlier this put together a program and
an understanding of what is expected
about colleges they want they want they
want our money they first of all we have
to see transparency how much is big how
much are they succeeding and when what
areas we need as a country if they don't
get those areas those those those those
metrics we get our money we take it back
put it someplace else so education is
the first thing one of the things that
just warm my heart really warm my heart
when I saw the rice in Minneapolis they
had this video of these black owners
black businesses just next to each other
yeah and in the window black owned a big
black dick black on and this was an
opportunity for all of us to see what it
passed over looks like because the the
locus and the the pillage of looters
passed over these businesses why because
it was his ar-15 sitting there on his
stove as a state these kids knowing that
it is show up here you can have some
ipsum issues they passed by to go to
those companies those businesses that
still believe in the bureaucracy is
gonna take gonna save them so those I
think those are the two top things is
education education will allow us to
have that mindset to go out and build
our own businesses build our property
which is important that's what the
pursuit of happiness was in place for
pursuit of property when that property
will be tangible property intellectual
property spiritual property passed down
through our kids our name those things
we work our lives to build at the end of
the day we on our last breath
which is way to say I'm so glad I live
because this is my legacy
that's what a property was really means
in order to protect that we need to be
educated to think about what it looks
like and has a vision to get there we
also have to have the tools protect
every single step of the way so nobody
can come in and steal it from us and we
now understand we've talked about
needing to have that that ability go to
these cities were they were just let
loose evils just let loose in these
cities we start to see what it really
looks like and where we can never let
that happen in our lifetime do you think
that that mindset of how to conquer all
of this is really the same mindset
whether you're an entrepreneur or a
professional athlete or a politician
that really wants to change things
properly that it is purely a mindset of
I am going to dedicate myself to this
relentlessly and see it fit and maybe
that's why you can see it as a former
NFL player where some people can't quite
see it because you know there's this
idea that somehow victimhood gives you
virtue these days or can't someone else
do it or or the Syst the rules are so
against me that I can't do it but it's
like if we think of all of our heroes
our sports heroes or fictional heroes
they did it they said it doesn't matter
how messed up the game is I'm gonna win
I'm gonna fix it
and you know that's that's what comes
out of a healthy environment that's what
came out of my community growing up your
parents when we had the idea first of
all life is not always quote fair life
is difficult and your people are going
to try to slow you down
but if you have the tenacity you can
dream because you've educated yourself
to know this possible and you have the
faith know that that you're just
especially anybody else then we can
overcome those obstacles the problem
with having in my community and we're
now having across the country and I say
this as authors I can what destroyed my
community was turned it upside down so
we see kids now that are acting like
victims and it's destroying their own
properties it was not white supremacist
has never has been white supremacist we
beat out white supremacists
it's been black elitist it's been those
with stealth those who look like me
those who talk like me those who put
their arms around said you know we're
gonna make things right and make things
till just all fear and they still out
there going to go to Congress the black
caucus the n-double-a-cp
your name them the elitist instead of
giving us
hope and tell us what we can do they
perfectly put in place impediments they
put in laws that make sure the poor
cannot become become wealthy a little
class them to make sure that our poor
black kids that never be educated why
cuz they're stuck because of this anti
choice that these black it leaders will
vote for and stand for and see their
people destroyed because they don't care
so it is truly elitism across the board
that's our enemy and I'll say this if we
go ahead and educate ourselves not to
what with the propaganda of the leftist
educate ourselves to our history educate
ourselves to what we the people done I
tell you Dave if we did that I'm just
real quick story I would never ever ever
I'm not a rate of racism never will be
but my point is but particularly for our
German and Mexican Americans will ever
look down or feel bad about that race
those people why because Martin when my
great great grandfather came here
nobility lationship they escaped North
South Carolina plantation and Burgess
plantation they went this southern and
western route of the Underground
Railroad guess who was who was making
that happen
Christian German Americas and Mexican
Americans opened up their doors open
their fields phantom gave them hope
along the way and what happened when
that got trip out west not only did my
great-great grandfather I understand he
could make great things happen but he
was able to forgive and we're not to be
a successful art or owned 102 acres of
land that he bought into a or two years
it can pay a pillar of his community
because along the way this travel you
realize that all white people aren't bad
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlists and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell